hey guys what's up
i can't help but stop streams like that
i haven't streamed in a while um because
i've just been really really really
really busy
uh stupid busy um and we're actually
just about to do a fun house gameplay
and i realized that the unit i would
like to record on is my
ps pro um and i don't have on this
account i haven't even finished the game
so i need to get through the tutorial
so that's what i'm doing uh this is
ghost of tsushima legends the
multiplayer mode for go to sushima
let me know if you guys can hear
everything okay i wrote the history of
tsushima
it's real pretty
no i right of the battle for its
survival
oh my gosh my gosh
look at you go um
so yeah this isn't going to be a uh
something
a long stream i gotta get back to work
i just thought i'd do that dude the
ghost of my fallen samurai
have returned also i think this is one
of the best games
to save us and um it's such a good
upgrade
been doing a great job with um updates
like the last of us part two updates as
well
just good stuff still don't know why not
multiple is coming out though huh i
haven't heard anything about that
this most recently said it was going to
be um an entirely different game
this is so tonally different to
uh the base game and i'm here
for it when the mongols
landed on our shores how am i i'm doing
okay thank you
terrible pretty good actually very tired
i
to fight it some say there is only
one ghost
first i will tell you of the samurai
we fought for the honor family
and home yes marcus it is a free update
though it is sort of a separate download
it's it's strange how it um
fits in but yes
you have to like have to go to the store
and because this is not my primary
console that i'm playing on right now
it um made me like
i have to put him down right now here
i'm about to play andy
[Music]
well at least he's not defending himself
that makes the situation
it's just as important as an attack
okay
i guess i still have to just walk in it
all right we'll just haul walk it's
fine cool
get out of here some attacks cannot
be blocked so warriors learned how to
dodge these blows hit me
warrior judging blows
you do get an upgrade through the story
that that if i remember correctly it
feels like this game came out [ __ ]
century ago
the ghosts carry many tools of work
night interrupt so good
with proper training
i mean if you'd let me attack him i feel
like i just i'd be fine
that's a bit of a [ __ ] what's this ah
brute force my way through that one
doesn't always work in this
call for the game my microphone's quiet
okay
i can turn it up a little bit
let's do about three decibels shall we
is that better looks like it's in the
yellow yeah it's a little bit quiet
hello
hey hey guys what's up welcome to the
stream
hey uh am i playing the story slam in 32
i already finished the story
um i think i finished it the week it
came out
um oh cool i did start it again though
um on my this here are capable of
channeling the power of
kami through the draining the
opponent's life eat
oh thank you peta i appreciate that
i don't remember how to lock the camera
on or is that not a thing like fully
forgotten how to play the game
i'm also i should mention playing this
right now because it's through my elgato
with a uh
about a second delay um
which as it turns out makes this a bit
tough
the delay is uh samurai master the
bitter first question
of explosive force you think a second is
not long until you have to
to edit with a second delay or
or uh play something that has any kind
of time base
because of goddamn disaster in their
victories there is a two-player story
mode as well we haven't done any of that
stuff
their achievements thank you jeremy
um i appreciate that he said as a max
level player i recommend you to play
samurai ronan you only have samurai to
start with right so i think i have to
don't i
uh yes samurai fight for honors
legacy and they're noble lords now
here's the reason
this game's so pretty it's ridiculous
this is a tutorial i'm like i should pop
out photo mode probably this is stunning
how long is this tutorial because i
would have said 20 minutes i hope i'm
right about that the ball
yes beaches a whole second of the way no
it's actually less than a second
single well-placed arrow
it is i think exactly 700 milliseconds
but it's still like enough of a delay
that it's a problem
big fan of god of war 707 madman you
probably already know that i'm hoping to
actually finally have edited
my um top five games of the generation
video today that i recorded
what three months ago i think it did it
in june able to focus
their senses and detect an enemy's
presence
from afar cool when they control the
high ground
i wanted to kill the pigs but i guess i
[ __ ] up i guess i have to i wanted to
jump down and chop them i guess i have
to shoot them
that's my bad blend into my chair i kind
of do
this is more of a mustard but it's
actually a little bit chilly in l.a
today
like only a little bit for the record
like very much just a little bit
not significantly chillest at all
um but enough that i can wear this
ghosts lightweight
valuable resources from the did i finish
what i was saying i don't know i'm so
tired
um i was saying
i am planning to have edited my top five
games of the year video that i recorded
back in august
today finally yeah
um and god of war
is what sparked me to think that because
god of war is up there
of the ghosts inspire villagers warriors
and lords across sushi yesterday all my
big unleaving gifts
as tribute
if your man don't want to lick it
deliver volunteers
some arrows pierce the thickest armor
while others contain the spirit of the
fire
am i burning this this seems like what
i'm burning
right nope
defeat the corrupted mongols okay you
want me to go back down is that what you
telling me to do i don't buy any of it
it seems like that's the way forward
all i'm saying
oh why don't you tell me to do it sooner
every time
i am not single gamer gaden i am not no
okay we're just gonna pay attention to
the wind
rather than to the level design that's
fine
hey punk create arrowheads
made of lightning to stun their foes
who is that i aim at oh you're down here
a bow can't be beat
very cool
like yo ass on fire is that everybody
they focus their aim so multiple arrows
fired at once
still hit their mark
why are the hunters from a distance
they're just totally
close uh i'm playing this on playstation
pro
this is uh i actually have the most new
playstation pro um
which is the uh am i allowed to jump
down now or am i gonna get no
um the death stranding pro i feel like
that gives me like a different
playstation experience to other people
sometimes and that um
you know those jokes about how your
playstation sounds like it's about to
take off
like the last of us mine's really quiet
for the art of stanford
and deception um
yogi i'm just doing the tutorial right
now because i thought i have work
and i have to be back at work at 2 30
but i need to get this done on this
console on this different account that i
don't tend to use um
so i'm just streaming it because i
haven't streamed in a really long time
i kept meaning to stream the new amnesia
i might try again
tonight but i've been so tired because
i'm
doing so much work right now unseen
through the grass
hidden from their enemies one thing that
i'm really excited to be able to tell
you guys about that i'm not allowed to
yet that is
especially time-consuming skilled
assassin can
end lives like as soon as i can tell you
it's a night
i uh i i'd be very excited and i feel
like um
i hope people will recognize the amount
of weapons often take to rooftops
and avoid the gaze of a watchable guard
but yeah i will have to stop playing
soon can you guys tell me when it's 2 30
actually so that uh
so that i know um this doesn't seem like
the right way to climb but i suppose
that it is
they fly quietly from roof to roof
as if carried by light time is it right
now
i don't even know this is way more
mythological than the base game yeah
which i think is really cool like
okay we have 11 minutes left doing all
right doing all right
they've lied across ropes and rigging
with effortless grace
all to line up the perfect kill
and visit death upon their victim
boom assassin's creed [ __ ] assassins
can vanish
into the air becoming invisible spirits
this is so cool the ultimate what a cool
free upgrade
what a good video game you know what i'm
saying just across the board
a good video game
an assassin's greatest skill is to
become an
unstoppable force of death moving like
lightning between foes
so do i have to be close to them
situation
sweet
beautiful beautiful both respected
and feared for creating a new art of war
based on stealth and adaptability
have i tried co-op yet um one final
ghost
house that is why i am doing this right
now the ronin
fought for the people uh so no i haven't
experienced it with other people
this is a game that people are
interested in me streaming like male 1
because i'm happy to get a squad
together and do that
um i think i want to do phasma phobia
again i'm doing
a stream tomorrow night for sure uh big
charity stream with a bunch of very cool
people
to raise money for uh black girls code
uh it'll be an among us stream 8 p.m
specific time as a
it'd be a bit obvious because i'm
streaming and be like wow elana weird
that you um
worked half of the day and then stopped
uh
when yeah it was a [ __ ]
come on um we stopped halfway through uh
as soon as you started streaming is when
you started feeling sick
people strange falls in battle
their allies never the ghosts marked
important
locations for their allies to find wall
nope it's going to be that
ghosts okay that is right
to aid them in battle yes boss
nobody told me i could do that
bro damn
do i have a slowdown in this
oh my gosh oh you're a good boy
now who the [ __ ] i forgot about them
yelling when they
guess everything 500 milliseconds ahead
elgato
phoning may be masterless but they do
not fight alone in time i do like a
healer class
you know as a woman
[Music]
spicy
come on mate come on let's just get it
done all right okay
there he goes that is actually an issue
that i had with this game
um it's the camera kind of being a [ __ ]
sometimes in combat
it's a recurring thing
a lot of games though the ghosts
cameras are off side by side against the
evil that threatens our home
awakened by mongol hordes how did i hurt
my knees
and i fainted and um i guess i just
smashed my knee on the tiles oh
more than ever which just not my finest
work
but it hurt for a while and i was like
this isn't getting better i've probably
done something wrong
help me the legends of sushi
patella fracture
it's pretty it's not bad though because
i can walk he was i'm surprised you can
walk so it's not a bad fracture
but a fraction nonetheless um
which is a bummer obviously okay
so i think i'm gonna go ronan because i
know that omar and james both went
samurai
and i like a gila
we don't want all samurais
uh should i be walking on it no um i
am i don't really walk very much right
now because of quarantine obviously um
so that's not too much of a concern
but i do have a brace and i have a
little footstool thing that i can put my
foot up on
um to try to keep it straight so that it
doesn't get injured more but i just
basically have to try to not bend it for
like four weeks
so that's where we're at it is broken i
broke my kneecap
it's just a really small break in that a
lot of people often
i guess like break it a lot worse mine
is very minor
but it still [ __ ] hurts um
i'm like virgil yeah exactly simon i did
it in solidarity with my boy
do i have plans to stream with aoc uh
look
i would but i don't think that she would
do that with me it's not
it's not a thing that i can choose to do
it's always funny when people are like
when are you coming to a convention in
this country and like as soon as they
ask
well like when are you going to dj in my
city whenever
that is an option for me uh
i can't uh will those things into
existence
um but yeah i thank you i do have five
more minutes but i should probably
head back to work be five minutes early
i'm a professional
uh this is obviously a really short
stream i just wanted to
hang out real quick say hi because i
haven't streamed in ages i will try to
tonight but i'm not gonna promise
anything we'll definitely be streaming
tomorrow we'll definitely be streaming
on saturday
i really gotta stream amnesia at some
point and hopefully do a bunch of spooky
games next week so
yeah thank you for watching for this
very short stream thank you for keeping
me on time i appreciate it you guys
alrighty have a good day everyone have a
good afternoon i gotta go back to work
just having a job is a thing that
happens